Deadpool rips off Captain America's face
and for good measure Deadpool gets nuked
in this comic so we are back with
uncanny Avengers number five and as
always for those of you guys who need to
get caught up you will find a link to
the follow ofex playlist at the end of
this but what this does is this
continues the fight that we saw at the
really the ending of the last video
which is Hydra Captain America facing
off against Captain America and The
Uncanny Avengers now for those of you
guys who are just joining us right now
probably for the first time you're kind
of like okay what in the world is going
on here long story short Marvel Comics
had a character named stevil like
literally St v i l Evil Steve it was
cool but he was essentially the result
of the Red Skull using a Cosmic Cube to
rewrite Captain America's entire history
actually turning him into a Hydra agent
ultimately that story was undone and the
traditional Captain America that we've
always known ended up coming back that
character of stevil was killed off he
was brought back to life by orcus the
government organization trying to kill
the mutant population across the world
because the goal here was to have him
masquerade as the X-Men version of
Captain America known as Captain kcoa
and then kill a whole bunch of humans
and when that happened it would be a way
for orcus to blame it on the mutant
population and further turn public
opinion against mutants and so it's a
really cool little element to the thing
but this ultimately comes to a head with
stevil being unmasked Captain America
realizing who it is and the two of them
fighting one another also a lot of you
guys were asking why Captain America has
a metal arm his arm was ripped off
earlier in this story and it was
replaced with a metal one so that's the
answer to your question in any event
because of the fact that this is stevil
this is one of the things that I want to
point out here and for a lot of you guys
who asked the question how capable is
Captain America really stevil is pretty
capable because he is Captain America in
every sense of the word with the
exception of how he thinks and the kind
of campaigns he goes on but in terms of
battle strategy fighting capability all
that kind of stuff he's every ounce the
Captain America meaning he knows all the
strengths and weaknesses of the
superhero Community with Captain America
subdued the first person he takes out is
Wade Wilson Deadpool because so long as
Deadpool is there to fight in any
meaningful capacity there's no way to
overcome him one because that guy is
crazier than this picture of Godzilla
with an afro and two because Deadpool
can always heal and always come back
from the dead and so the result of this
is that with him out of the picture it
kind of lead everybody there you do have
psylock and you have Mona St Croy
they're both basically telepaths they're
relatively easy to deal with the biggest
issue he has to contend with is trying
to fight what isn't effect two Ninjas at
the same time there's also Black Widow
but like really who cares and so what
ends up happening is that while Monae St
Croy is able to momentarily get the
upper hand he's able to incapacitate her
with a headbutt and then in turn like
smashes the ground sends this girl
flying through the ground grabs his
shield and then Captain America grabs
Deadpool who was cut in half by stevil
shield and actually throws him at stevil
and then in turn he just like grabs him
by the face and starts to pull his face
off which is kind of crazy now at that
moment you basically transition to Rogue
now for those of you guys who are asking
why are there X-Men and Avengers on this
team this is what's called the unity
Squad this is not the first time that a
team like this has appeared Rogue is
returning and Deadpool is returning but
the unity Squad was actually a concept
that was thought of after the events of
Avengers versus X-men because the two
groups almost killed each other Captain
America had this idea of as a way to
kind of bridge the gap between the two
they would form a team where both groups
would basically work together and they
could always be sharing information with
the other group not really as spies but
like being aware of what the others are
doing that was the idea of the unity
Squad right quite literally creating
Unity between the Avengers and the X-Men
and so because of that this team even in
its capacity this has Rogue chiming into
Captain America and saying like sorry to
interrupt with like everything that's
going on but the nuke that stevil
planted at Empire State University is
about to go off in less than a minute
and it's booby trapped and it seems like
it's only got one off button attached to
a retinal scanner now this is where the
telepaths become important because
that's where you have steil who's like I
can stop it and the response of Captain
America is then so can I because you
literally are exactly me down to the
genetic level but the telepaths kick in
and they're like nope it's a trap that
the entirety of the retinal scanner is
built with an atomizer and the instant
you put your eye up to it it's going to
disintegrate you which is actually
pretty ingenious to be honest with you
guys it's a pretty smart maneuver
because telepath just saved Captain
America's life so that's kind of cool of
course they ultimately end up
incapacitating stevil then they take to
the rooftops and that's when Captain
America kind of sends out the message to
basically every everybody right he tells
Rogue that that bomb cannot detonate
here he says I'm sorry I wish there were
another way but you have to move it out
of New York maybe up into space But
ultimately rog's on the mission anyway
now stevil does like kind of chime in
for a second and just like talk some
trash and just kind of make fun of them
a little bit and he even like sort of
torments Deadpool and it's like did you
ever tell Rogue how you felt because
much like all of us growing up in the
1990s and watching X-Men the Animated
Series
Deadpool's got a thing for rogue don't
lie we all know it's true so here's the
thing once stevil puts asleep Captain
America kind of tells everybody right
he's like this is Steve Rogers I have an
Avenger down and need help at Area 51
there's going to be a nuclear detonation
and then Deadpool just kind of whisks
away and so once this bomb is taken to
Area 51 Quicksilver is the one that
whisks him away because Quicksilver is
also a part of this team as well but
here's a cool thing one I don't think
we've ever seen a quicksilver Deadpool
teamup and while this isn't really
necessarily enough for me to just kind
of be like I absolutely need to see this
if Marvel wrote a comic I'd probably
check out the first issue to be honest
with you guys but the the real important
thing here is he basically tells Wade as
you know Rogue has the ability to copy
the powers of other people he says we'll
have a fraction of a second to save
rogue's Life by sharing your healing
factor with her I cannot outrun the bomb
after it detonates so I'm going to get
you close and pin you down but it will
be up to you to hold on and so when
Rogue lands the bomb almost immediately
goes off and Rogue is completely
incinerated by this thing now I'm not
100% sure how I feel about this and the
reality here is it feels a little
inconsistent in rogue's storytelling and
the reason why is because Rogue is a
character is ridiculously powerful she's
every bit as capable as like Captain
Marvel heral Danvers because For the
Longest Time Rogue just like siphoned
Powers off of people and in fact in the
old Avengers annual number 10 I think it
was it was a Chris Claremont story where
Rogue infiltrated The Avengers and
essentially took Thor's powers and in
doing so basically gave herself the
ability to lift Thor's hammer that was
back in the day when Thor's ability to
lift his hammer was part and partial as
just part of his power set and like that
was it but the thing about it is that I
don't really see a reason why she
wouldn't be able to withstand a nuclear
strike I I mean I don't know this feels
like more something of opinion than
anything else let me know what you guys
think down in the comment section but
the reality here is that Quicksilver
whisk him in Deadpool is basically
thrown on top of Rogue and then
Quicksilver whisks himself back out and
this of course allows Deadpool to grab
the hand of Rog and so as she's being
incinerated but not quite dead she's
able to absorb his healing factor and
she's able to survive now for Deadpool
this is the thing and a lot of you guys
probably know this but a lot of you guys
probably don't know why so Deadpool's
healing Factor being this crazy and this
advanced was not always that way right
the old Rob lield Comics like you know
what is it New Mutants issue number 98
where Deadpool first showed up he was
just a guy with a healing Factor like
wolver rain and that was it it was not
until I think it was the Joe Kelly story
Funeral For A Freak when Deadpool
completely regrew an entire body from
one hand that that became like a normal
part of his repertoire that story is the
reason why Deadpool's healing Factor
exists the way that it does I just kind
of felt like sharing that with everybody
but with him basically saving Rogue you
get this kind of hilarious moment right
where it's like you know I've been
meaning to ask what do you see in Gambit
anyway and the response of Rogue is like
thank you Wade right and he's like you
never have to thank me and he's like
does Gambit make you think
him I mean what Rogue sees in Gambit is
that he's got very much a devil make
here kind of attitude and he's
persistent man the guy refuses to give
up and then ultimately he started
betting Rogue so I guess it all paid off
but with Steve really defeated not
actually destroyed but defeated it's
really been uck that saves the
reputation of everybody because under
normal circumstances with a story like
this and really with any kind of an
event like this you really have a
situation where things would kind of
wind down and then nobody would really
understand the intricacies of what was
happening damage control would come in
they would clean up the mess and then
public sentiment would be people just
believing what they want to believe and
that's really it with bin urick as a
reporter while he's not really changing
heart minds of everybody who is
staunchly anti-mutant he is able to get
the accurate information out there and
the information is exactly what we
already knew right that basically people
were already aware of steil's existence
and then steil's ultimate demise and he
basically just said like they brought
him back to life like orcus did and so
it is a way to kind of point the finger
in saying orcus is doing some pretty
shady stuff but again public sentiment
doesn't really change here because
people who are Starly anti-mutant are
like hey look do what you got to do to
win win the fight and that's it right
they don't really care how orcus wins so
long as they win and so what this does
is it picks up with stevil who is going
to the courthouse he is standing trial
but the guy's got a whole new outfit
with like a whole white like suit and
everything it looks pretty dope and he
gives this amazing speech right one of
the first things that happens here
though is one of the cops tells him your
secret Empire persever sir so that means
that there are people who are still
loyal to him Hydra in the ideologies
that he created it but what he ends up
becoming is a kind of William Striker
type character although he does actually
adopt a name for himself so what he says
is he says I believe that every human
being will stand shoulder to- shoulder
that we can finally emerge from the
shadow of Fear cast Over Us by the
mutants and their ilk I'm not a cruel
man in my dream the mutants are also
side by side with their own kind and
they are at peace too of course not
telling people my dream is basically
Days of Future Past where all the
mutants are dead and he says when
someone tells you who they are believe
them the mutants told us their truth
they are different they have their own
laws they have an entire planet to
themselves and basically Mars I.E the
mutants called it oraco and he says man
loves mutant kills and that's really
where I say William Striker because that
was the story that introduced William
Striker those of you guys who don't know
who he is he was a religious
fundamentalist who believed it was his
mission from God to kill mutants there
was a point where he blew up a packed
School Bus it was kind of nuts and he
says and what fear do the mutants have
of death it's a revolving door for them
we should not have to ask so I'll only
ask once leave man in peace and when the
mutants ascended and threatened our
world poisoning our medicine did the
flag protect you I.E did Captain America
Protect you unfortunately no he fought
for this flag he says I fought for this
flag hell I died for this flag but like
my misguided counterpart like Captain
America I've returned and I'm changed I
know it's not this flag's fault we let
the stars and stripes down this flag was
once the symbol of a nation of men and
it is the government that let down
Mankind and so from now on I shall be a
flag Smasher so basically Steve will
becomes a new flag Smasher right who
really cares somebody throws like a cup
at his face it's one of these things
where like him becoming flag Smasher is
Marvel just kind of being like so this
guy might return for another story
like I don't know maybe it'll be cool in
the Captain America comics who knows
you'll probably never see him again but
the thing about this is that it is just
kind of The Uncanny Avengers team just
kind of being like Okay cool so not
everybody's buying into his jargon
that's cool people who were slly
anti-mutant are still anti-mutant people
who are staunchly in support of mutants
are still in support of mutants and
that's really it so The Uncanny Avengers
celebrate all their actions black
widow's there and I don't even know why
because she actually didn't really do
anything and yeah that's the ending of
uncanny Avengers with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
if you guys need to get caught up on the
entirety of fall of X as always make
sure you click this link to the playlist
and I will catch you all later peace